There's more to this drone than meets the eye.
The team behind this 'bot took inspiration from
nature to design a device capable of morphing
to suit its environment, transforming to most
efficiently tackle the challenge in front of it.
Animals use their bodies in various ways to suit
different terrain. Meerkats may not be great at
walking on two legs but they can stand up when
they need to to scout out their surroundings.
Turtle flippers may be optimized for swimming
but they can also haul the reptiles up a beach
when needed. And it was this ability to
use appendages for multiple functions
that inspired the design of this robot named the
multimodal mobility morphobot or M4 for short.
M4 isn't the first robot to move in multiple ways
but the researchers behind it say that previous
designs mostly fell into one of two camps those
with 'morpho' functionality like this robot that
can reshape its limbs to walk or swim, or those
that use redundancy - having a set of wheels and
propeller blades to travel on land or the sea. But
M4 is different, it can perform a variety of tasks
by using its same limbs in different ways just
like an animal changing its posture or gait - thus
finding a sweet spot between redundancy and the
ability to change shape and function. In practice
what this means is that M4 can fly and roll as
you might expect, but also tumble over obstacles.
Balance on one end. Crouch under
barriers. And crawl over rocky terrain.
It can even manipulate this ball using
two of its propellers like hands.
When presented with a 45 degree ramp too steep
for wheels alone, the team took inspiration from
the Chukka Partridge which uses its wings to
help it run up inclines. They instructed M4
to do something similar. M4 could of course just
fly up the ramp, but rotors use much more energy
than wheels and so by combining the two modes M4
can achieve the same goal much more efficiently.
The researchers argued that this morphobot
could be used for everything from search
and rescue to future space missions and
want to expand on their design to give
M4 more sophisticated tools and greater
articulation. They are also working on
algorithms that could allow M4 to interpret
data from sensors and autonomously choose its
mode of transport based on its surroundings -
be that rolling flying or something in between.